[Music]
[Music]
on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good evening i'm pierce morgan
uncensored tonight is it time to call
putin's nuclear bluff ex-special forces
hero and tv tough guy and middleton will
be here to discuss that and who better
to talk about the burning issue of trans
athletes in sport than the most famous
trans woman in the world caitlyn jenner
will be here live too but first it's my
brain dumb
i want to start with ukraine where
vladimir putin continues to show the
world he's the new hitler as he commits
monstrous genocidal barbarism against a
european democracy the deluded dictator
claims he's waging war over what he
calls the denarcification of ukraine the
truth is that what he's doing is the
nazification of ukraine and the only
difference between what hitler did in
world war ii and what putin's doing now
is that now the west is standing back
and letting him get on with it
putin thinks he's got us over a barrel
because he keeps threatening to use his
nuclear arsenal if anyone tries to stop
him and we keep recalling in fear and
horror when he does and assuring us not
what we're going to do
well just last night he was at it again
warning that russia has weapons nobody
else has and he's ready to use them
should we intervene
but as donald trump told me early in the
week he shouldn't be allowed to throw
around the n-word as a protective shield
when he bombs maternity hospitals
targets refugees as they flee to safety
and incinerates holocaust survivors in
their homes
take a look at this clip i'm about to
show you it's a montage of some of these
atrocities going on in the ukraine it's
a hard watch but it's the watch we must
all see
and ask yourself one question as you're
watching
what is our red line
that's what's going on here
it's genocide at what point do we call
putin's bluff and directly engage with
him to protect the ukrainian people from
yet more of his hideous slaughter we're
watching war crimes in real time acts of
depravity is wicked as any in modern
history and as we're watching we're also
sitting on the most advanced and
powerful military force ever seen in
nato
will when will enough be enough
the single argument against using
western conventional military might to
blast russia out of ukraine is fear that
it would drag us into a conflict with a
nuclear enemy and potentially trigger
world war three that's what putin wants
us to fear
he's relying on us to do nothing because
we haven't got the moral backbone to
stand up to him
but a nuclear deterrent supposed to be
there for protection
it's not a free pass for dictators to
decimate sovereign democratic countries
without fear of consequence
and putin knows if he fires one nuclear
weapon in anger he and his entire
country will be eviscerated why would
someone like him who spent his whole
life craving power and wealth and
hoardering luxury possessions risk
losing everything if we let him win in
ukraine he'll come for more countries
once a bully smells weakness and fear
they never stop bullying and we all know
that bullies only understand one
language a punch on the nose the
question really now is do we have the
guts to give him one or do we let the
brave ukrainians continue to die in huge
numbers and have their country destroyed
the palace of westminster is a stunning
gothic monument to democracy in the
middle of london an awe-inspiring symbol
of british honor and integrity for 700
glorious years we've elected members of
parliament to defend our rights to
uphold our values and now apparently
to watch porn
yep two female mps reported an unnamed
male conservative member of parliament
for watching x-rated content on his
mobile phone as he sat in the house of
commons in full view of his colleagues
it's pretty unbelievable that any
elected official in the public purse
could be so reckless and stupid and of
course deeply insensitive to the
horrified women sitting near him but
it's also reflective of a deeper malaise
inside british politics right now three
government ministers and two opposition
lawmakers are all currently being
investigated for alleged sexual
misconduct
government officials from the prime
minister down are also being handed
police fines for breaking their own laws
to party during lockdowns
the public are entitled in my opinion to
expect higher standards of personal
probity from those they elect to run the
country when mps think it's okay to
scroll through porn on their phones as
they're supposed to be engaging in vital
parliamentary debate during a pandemic
and a european war
it's pretty clear that a dismal culture
of lavish misbehavior exists now at the
heart of british democracy and that
can't be tolerated this mp if found
guilty should be removed from parliament
talking of removal from classless to
cashless the name alex jones may not be
familiar to you until i replay an old
clip from the time he screamed at me
about guns on american television
how many gun murders were there oh
you're gonna ban your festival britain
last year
uh how many uh chimpanzees can dance on
the head of a pin the tyrants did it
hitler took the guns stalin took the
guns mal took the guns but el castro
took the gun hugo chavez took the guns
and i'm here to tell you
1776 will commence again if you try to
take our firearms
oh i hear you cry that crazy guy well
jones isn't just crazy he's a nasty
piece of work who built a gigantic
online following with his infowars
website and made many millions of
dollars peddling mad conspiracy theories
about the us government his most vile
claim was that the 2012 sandy hook mass
shooting was faked
very few tragedies have ever moved me
more profoundly than that appalling
massacre in which 20 children aged
between 6 and 7 were shot dead in their
classrooms by a lone lunatic
but alex jones responded to what
happened by saying it was all a
government staged hoax perpetrated by
crisis actors to justify new gun control
laws being introduced
it was a disgusting lie that caused
immeasurable new grief and misery to the
poor families of the children who died
but 10 of those families decided to sue
him for defamation and they won and they
won big now jones a great government
conspiracy theorist
has filed for bankruptcy as he awaits
details of the huge damages he'll now
have to pay
and he's been reduced to desperately and
pathetically begging the same government
he has always said is the enemy of the
people for bankruptcy relief oh the
irony
jones deserves everything coming his way
what he did to those sandy hook families
was beyond despicable he's been morally
bankrupt for decades now he'll be
financially bankrupt too and hopefully
that means he'll never again be able to
lead such a vile smear campaign like the
one he did to desecrate the memory of
those 20 young children
i'm talking to children i'm old enough
to remember when disney's soul focus was
to entertain kids but now it also wants
to govern how they're educated the
reasons that completely baffled me the
family-friendly movie company recently
abandoned this historic stance of not
engaging in any partisan politics to
wage a public battle with florida's
governor and potential presidential
candidate ron desantis it's all about a
law banning schools from teaching
children as young as five about sexual
and gender preferences disney bosses
originally said they wouldn't get
involved and they were bullied into
speaking out against the supposed don't
say gay bill after many of his own angry
woke staff staged walkouts and protests
but putting aside your own opinions
about the bill itself and it doesn't
actually say by the way don't say gay
anywhere
what does have this any of this have to
do with disney
most florida parents i would guess
probably agree with desantis that they
should ultimately decide what their
young children get told about sex and
gender and if disney's really that
concerned about morality when will we
hear it stop streaming to countries
where it's illegal to be gay
or making movies in china where the
uyghur muslims are suppressed have we
heard disney speak out against the
weaker muslim suppression
have we hell
sadly this is yet another example of
corporate cowardice and hypocrisy in the
in the face of the woke mob
and i predict that disney will soon
regret ever getting involved in politics
or perhaps they'll just go the full hog
and woke wash their movies to avoid
upsetting any of their sensitive
snowflake woke force i can see the
hurriedly revised billboards now
peter sexual
snow mixed heritage and the seven
vertically challenged individuals
lady in the economically disadvantaged
person
and of course my personal favorite
pocahontas starring meghan markle now
you might be thinking i'll come off it
piers
but trust me there will be people at
disney right now already thinking about
it
well more on woke disney with a great
guest in just a moment before we go any
further i want to talk about my good
friend sharon osbourne she was here on
uncensored last night talking about
council culture the devastating year she
had since she was cancelled for
supporting me over the markle debacle
and about her new tv show on the talk on
talk tv called the talk well i'm very
sad to say that her husband ozzy uh
caught covid19 he touched it positive
overnight and because of his underlying
health conditions should be very serious
in recent years sharon understandably
has flown back immediately to be in
america with her husband and she has uh
released this statement when she was
interviewed by a reporter earlier
ozzy
um was only diagnosed it was like the
middle of the night our time but
i spoke to him and he's okay
you must be so worried about him
i am very worried about aussie right now
we've gone two years without him
catching covid and it's just ozzy's luck
he would get it now
what's the first thing you'll do when
you get back
um
hold him and kiss him but with about
three masks on i think
oh my family's my life
are you sad to be missing the show
i can't believe my luck
that um
i'm missing the show i've already been
there three days
it's
it's i can't believe it three days and
i'm
i'm missing the show but um i will be
back i will i know i will it'll take me
a week
to get my old man back on his feet again
and i will be back in a week how are the
family coping with aussies covered
unfortunately
um
it's
he was diagnosed in the middle of the
night they're all sleeping so i haven't
spoken to them yet but they'll rally
around they'll be with him
when will we see you back on air
you're going to see me back on it in a
week because
i know my husband
we're going to get him back on his feet
and we're going to get a negative test
by next week absolutely heartbreaking
development for the osbourne family i
know uh from speaking to sharon earlier
how desperately worried she is about
aussie uh again because of the
underlying health conditions that he's
had
and she's flown back to be with him
understandably she sent me a text from
the airport it's just a nightmare
appears i'm at the airport now i feel
like the osborne's are cursed and
they've certainly had a terrible run of
bad luck i want to send sharon all my
love to aussie as well my best wishes
for a very full and speedy recovery and
everyone here at talk tv and appears
uncensored is right behind you willing
you on so good luck to you aussie
now let's get back to the woke disney
company and his intervention into
politics plus two other hollywood
stories the tordrey johnny depp and
amber heard soap opera continuing in
court and the whiny self-pitying alec
baldwin with new audio which reveals him
moaning about losing work following the
fact that he shot somebody dead on the
set of his movie rust to discuss all
this it's one of those prominent
conservative tv hosts in america started
to say megan kelly of the meghan kennedy
show joins me now megan how lovely to
have you on the show
hi pierce congrats it's great to see you
thank you we're great to have you and so
much to talk about about i know one of
our mutually favorite topics hollywood
and the sort of rancid hypocrisy which
pervades tinsel town at the best of
times i want to go through all three of
these things with you start with disney
because disney's original position over
this supposed don't say gay bill issue
in florida was that their new ceo was
gonna do nothing he said we just don't
get involved in politics that's always
been their position before and i
applauded that i thought what a sensible
position for anyone to take and then of
course the white brigade internally at
disney came for him and basically
bullied him
into speaking out against the bill and
now all hell's broken at least what do
you make of it yeah
well first of all they started off by
misrepresenting what was in the bill at
all all the bill says is that you can't
in curriculum be teaching five to eight
or nine-year-olds k through third grade
um
sexual identity or gender identity
lessons that's it in curriculum that's
too early it's too young uh and then
beyond that whatever lessons are brought
should be age-appropriate that's all the
law said these teachers who are like i'm
not going to be able to talk about my
partner with the children you can
mention your partner and if the child
says what is a partner what do you mean
why didn't you say wife you can say i
don't have a wife i have a husband even
though i'm a man because we're in a gay
relationship that's fine you can't get
into curriculum with
gay
uh trans all of that that needs to wait
and it doesn't stop a parent from
teaching his or her child at home about
about all that anyway okay so disney
misrepresented the bill
and what happened was the the ceo
initially said i'm not going to comment
on i'm not going to do anything but then
bob iger too the old ceo was on the
sidelines and they don't like each other
and he tweaked the guy like oh well i
would have said something and then the
new guy has no spine and inside the
wokksters are saying oh we this is awful
we should do something about this fake
don't say gay bill which is a misnomer
and he caved so that guy has no spine
whatsoever and he's gotten disney into a
world of hurt now because they've lost
15 points on their stock they've lost
billions of dollars since they've gotten
into this fight with the state where
they should have stayed politically
neutral and at the same time all of this
happened uh somebody leaked internal
disney videos showing that they actually
do in their own words have a secret
queer agenda and that they in their
words are trying to sneak it into films
and product wherever possible so they've
taken a hard-line stance with the
woksters against not just america but
floridians the polls there show that and
the democrats are in favor of this law
right i saw that and that doesn't
surprise me i think a lot of parents
would be in favor of that um but putting
that aside is the fact that disney felt
compelled because of their internal woke
force
to actually change their position on it
was what was so fascinating to me and
also it does expose them doesn't it to
charge of rank hypocrisy because disney
still streams their movies making a lot
of money to countries where it's
literally illegal to be gay and of
course they have a huge box of this
market now in china where you see the
weak muslims are being you know
persecuted not a word from disney about
their horror about what's going on there
so their morality is very localized
very central to this one little issue in
in florida but not the wider morality of
inconsistent moral policies around the
world
of course and what are they so upset
about in disney i mean in in florida
with respect to ron desantis and his
bill that that you can't sit down a
kindergartner and say you need to
understand what it what it means to be a
girl who thinks she's a boy we're
talking about that right now as part of
our curriculum they're trying to learn
their abcs
that's what disney's upset about but the
forced sterilization of the women and
the people being taken off to the
concentration camps
no problem that's you know somebody
else's problem we saw the same stuff i
had mark cuban on my podcast lamenting
racism in america and the alleged racism
of all these cops in his head
and uh he said you know you've got to
just do the right thing blm needs to go
on the courts and i said
what about your support in the nba for
china what about the fact that you get
billions of dollars from them do you
feel the need to speak up about that at
all yeah the apocalyptic peers wouldn't
speak out oh i condemn all human rights
abuses oh in china
china but that's the problem very few
people will condemn china because of
commercial interest i want to talk to
you very quickly uh megan i've got you
about these two other hollywood things
first of all johnny depp and amber we
don't want to waste much time on this
but have you ever had a more repellent
public squabble than these two now
second caught back i want to play a
little clip of some of the tawdry
highlights listen to this
the tip of my finger
had been
severed
cigarettes out on someone else you have
consequences reactions that's it shut up
i'm sorry that i didn't
uh uh hit you
across the face in a proper slot but i
was hitting you it was not punching you
babe you're not punched
the jury judge thing tell the world
johnny tell them johnny
tell the world johnny tell them johnny
depp i johnny depp a man
i'm a victim too of domestic violence
i said yes
i am
i don't know about you i'm just seeing
two actors clearly damaged clearly hate
each other clearly were involved in
extensive mutual abuse of all different
varieties and i just it makes me puke to
be honest with you the whole thing yeah
the selfishness and the sound of the
kind of self-obsessiveness of it all
it's a lesson for everybody sitting at
home if you think that these hollywood
celebrities have a better life than you
do just because they have a lot of re a
lot of money and they have these
beautiful homes think again uh because
there's an emptiness inside that cannot
be filled by fame or unlimited spending
and these two are a perfect example of
that but i do think that this case is
important
and i've been following it you know not
i've been watching the trial every day
but i've been following it closely
enough piers and i think
he wasn't wrong to file the lawsuit and
here's why she came out in that
washington post op-ed and said i'm a
victim of domestic abuse and you know
i've suffered all the consequences of
that and we all knew it was about johnny
depp and that's he said he was defamed
and he said he lost his pirates of the
caribbean deal
and what this trial has shown us is
she
she gave as good as she got
there's been very little evidence of him
harming her and there's been a ton of
evidence of her harming him but i think
in the end i think in the end it doesn't
really matter to me she won the first
case he might win this one she might
want to get i don't think either of them
win i think it's so tordry it's so awful
that most people look at it and go
you're both as bad as each other and i
mean you make a good one but i do think
so he's not going to win his legal claim
he's not going to win a defamation case
against her but he as a pr matter has
shown the world that she was hitting him
regularly she hurt him regularly and the
evidence of him doing it to her is very
little so far so we'll see how this
plays out but i think as a pr matter
he's made his point uh abuse can go both
ways yeah and so it's important
to know exactly what she did yeah she's
no angel whatsoever just finally alec
baldwin has been going on this six-month
self-pity tour since he shot a woman
dead accidentally i'm absolutely
prepared to say that from everything
we've gleaned about this but helena
hutchins is cinematographer on the set
of his film rust
is dead because a gun in alec baldwin's
hand was fired and killed her and he
seems to be going out of his way ever
since to make himself look like the
victim new audio overnight released by
the police which had him saying this
it was really tough because i have six
daughters today kids happened she
started to cry she said i'm going to go
to school and everyone's going to make
fun of me
my eight-year-old
half the jobs i had lined up between now
and they said the second half of the
earth
we haven't got along megan what do you
make of alec baldwin's self political
because it's all about him
no one cares no one cares about him at
all a woman was shot by him and he knew
it and his first thoughts were for
himself and that's how it's been all
along in his interview with abc saying
he feels no guilt well phil's not killed
no he's been botching this is a pr
matter from start to finish and
meanwhile he's been hanging out his
entire crew to dry from the get-go
that's what the most recently released
documents show as well he'll hang up the
the working-class people on his set
he'll have no sympathy for anyone but
himself and if this thing has done
anything on the positive because there's
been so much on the negative it's shown
us who he really is
he really is a narcissistic bully
unbelievably selfish and narcissistic
and made it all about him but in fact
there's a grieving uh widower and a
young child who's lost his mother uh
megan could talk to you all night thank
you so much come back soon really
enjoyed talking to you
great to see you
and since the next russian state media
is now openly discussing the prospect of
nuclear war is it more evidence of
putin's great nuclear bluff though i'll
give you my thoughts next and talk to at
middleton
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so vladimir putin's once again
threatened to use nuclear force if any
other nation intervenes in the ukraine
war and even russian state television is
now telling viewers a nuclear war is
probable so let me bring in now british
british special forces war hero at
middleton and great to see you thanks
for coming to the studio to have you
here thanks for having me start with the
ukraine war what's your gut feeling here
my feeling about putin is he knows that
he's got us over a barrel that he's got
this big nuclear arsenal and all he has
to do is wave it at us and we all run a
mile that goes against every instinct
that i've ever had about dealing with a
genocidal maniac
what's your view though obviously it's
complicated obviously it's yeah it's got
risk but what do we do about this guy
well when you've got someone barking as
much as putin about nuclear weapons
first of all you ask yourself two
questions one does he have that
capability and two
is he has he got the min rules has he
got the balls to use that capability i
would say no a third obviously so don't
say what would be his motivation to
start a war that would lead to the
immediate destruction of himself
and his own country it would be the next
world war three basically what he's done
he's uh he's gone into ukraine
that they're amazing people their
fighting force is holding the fort at
the moment you know don't think that the
russians are going in there and having
an easy time because they're certainly
not i know people who are on the ground
in ukraine and um you know they're
they're quite happy at the moment
actually because they're actually they
think they're genuinely holding them
they they think they can generally beat
them but putin can be in this for the
long term we've seen his track record in
these situations he might be doing this
for years the guy's unstable it's clear
to see when i saw his first interview
with putin i saw how unstable he was and
i thought to myself wow this guy's got
potential to do something crazy but the
amount of barking that he's doing and
the amount of uh sort of talking that
he's doing especially about nuclear
deterrence and nuclear weapons
i think that he's just he's see that
he's at his wit's end now and now he's
trying to
divert people by by making the noise of
that he's got if he invaded a nato
country we would be morally compelled to
get involved
i don't see a lot of moral difference
between
that and what's happening in ukraine
other than ukraine is not a member of
nato yet
you know i just feel do we not at some
point have a moral duty to get involved
with conventional weapons given nato is
so powerful well what we've got to
realize is not a game of poker you know
people are saying oh is he bluffing
should we go in there it's it's more
sensitive than that if we go in there um
it's going to cost
millions more lives it's going to start
world war iii let's be honest um we
either look at the situation and go
right do we now come together as nato
and
strike first or do we hold back and and
see what putin is up to but
it's it's a catch-22 it's one of those
where if nuclear weapons are involved
then you know it's world war three we
shouldn't be able to use the nuclear
capability as a protective shield to
genocide which is what's going on it's
supposed to supposed to be mutually
assured destruction system when neither
side would ever use it both sides have
it you know
nato and russia both have it but we both
understand that what capabilities
if he keeps saying if you do anything
i'll use it that's the misuse of the
nuclear deterrent isn't it yeah the more
time he he gives like that the the more
we think to ourselves right it's it's
just a bluff he's he's just he's just
well that's my gun
but also he can't he can't have the the
liberty of the freedom to keep doing
that no there's something has to be done
about it you know that's what i feel it
has to be a time scale where people
where we say as nato as the uk we say
right enough is enough this is when we
need to strike or this is the the the
action that we need to take uh i agree i
know i believe we're reaching that point
pretty quickly you talked about the
ukrainian spirit of the people they are
quite extraordinary and it really
reminds me i think of what i think is
becoming a sort of rarity in our society
certainly here and you see in america
you see it in australia around the world
now where there's almost a premium on
not having resilience or mental strength
everyone talks all the time about mental
weakness in a way and
society seems to me to have got a bit
soft yeah what do you think is going on
here and where do we how can we get the
kind of spirit you see the ukrainians
showing well it's the whole wokeness
isn't it it's sort of taken over it's
it's everything's uh pampy-pampy
feelings and emotions and ultimately
it's about facts you know it's
especially with ukraine the fact is your
country has been invaded you have to now
you know
um deep deep into that psychological
reserve and go right listen this has
happened now we need to we need to you
know all come together and we need to
stay resilient and we need to fight back
or those that have been forced the
children women have been forced to
especially children i've talked about
this to my wife from when i say about
the children i've been forced to
understand about war you know these
should be innocent children are going
about their everyday lives going to
school learning growing growing up and
understanding who they are they're
having to learn about war from the young
age of five so i think we should be i
would love to see people like you going
into schools teaching kids about
perspective about resilience about
mental strength i don't see any of that
the whole debate is skewed towards
almost almost celebrating weakness
turning everyone into victims everyone's
complaining about the healthy
communities
they're like woe is me and they go on
instagram and all this kind of thing i
want to show you a little clip this this
is the opposite in a way this is what's
give me hope for the future it's a young
eight-year-old kid called jack and he
plays at sember a famous rugby school in
the north of england this is him when he
one of his little teammates was upset
jack decided to grasp the metal look at
this
it's okay
trust me look at me look at me bob i'm
the shortest kid here listen it doesn't
matter who you are it doesn't matter if
you're short you're young it doesn't
matter if you're taller it doesn't
matter if you fight it doesn't matter
rugby player you understand that you're
insane you are actually insane for your
way you're safe
the best scene though ever
best team really good come on come on
the other kid was called bob good on
jack
you know when i see that i think that's
the spirit
right don't just quit don't just lie on
the floor i talked to tyson furiously
about rocky balboa it's not about many
times you get knocked over it's how many
times in life you can get back up and
keep moving forward and keep punching
that's what resilience is all about but
in schools they don't teach that now you
know the healthy competition where no
one is about participating no one's
first no one second no one's heard it's
like you know we want to be winners we
are a nation of winners you know that
kid is the biggest hyped guy we have a
great start a great start came out the
other day the oscar winners who win
oscars live on average about five or six
years longer and they researched a
thousand oscar winners nominees the
nominees who lost right which was final
proof to me but no one wants to lose
winning actually makes you live longer
no one wants the silver or bronze medal
with everyone i don't know
you know i must debate every olympics
yeah it celebrates losing but why why is
there a silver and gold medal it should
be um silver and bronze medal should be
a gold medal one or nothing i totally
agree with it you know the world's gone
the world doesn't need to toughen up and
and all seriousness with ukraine is it's
a sad state of affairs and it's about
time that we realize that that the facts
are
we need resilience we need to be strong
we need to you know when when everything
is crumbling around us like it is with
you so i hope it gets people subjective
these ukrainian people are showing such
unbelievable courage and resilience and
inspiring inspiring personal behavior
when everybody else is squealing about
stuff it just doesn't matter um i've got
to leave it because there's a genuine
former olympic gold medalist ready for
me caitlyn jenner let's do
gold decathlon medal for the united
states uh before becoming the most
famous trans woman in the world so i'll
talk to her in a moment
great to see you uh i know you got
ridiculously cancelled off your show in
the uk that show's never been the same
since you've gone on to better things so
great to see you thank you very much
peace all the best
well it says the next uh brash fearless
antagonistic is free speech absolutist
elon musk the saver of twitter the
founder of wikipedia has a strong viewer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
the billionaire and free speech warrior
elon musk has bought twitter but what
happens next he's joked on the platform
that he'll be buying coca-cola to put
cocaine back in he'll make the platform
maximum fun he says but responding to a
meme admitted he can't make miracles
happen and fix all the ice cream
machines in mcdonald's
joking aside ultimately he says he wants
twitter to be politically neutral which
effectively means upsetting the far
right and the far left equally well
hurrah to that but how will he do it and
can he do it i'm joined now by sky news
australia presenter erin mullen and
co-founder of wikipedia jimmy wells
welcome to both of you let me start with
you erin
over there in australia
um my first reaction when i heard this
and i'm a twitter shareholder so i have
a vested interest in it not collapsing
my first reaction was good because elon
musk is a maverick billionaire genius
but he believes passionately in free
speech
isn't it bizarre that you look at
someone who's spending 44 billion
dollars to buy an asset and that the
selling line the mission statement so to
speak is i just want to make everyone
absolutely miserable that is so twitter
it is so brilliant
it's like
can he do it i don't know is he the
right person i don't know not many other
people have the kind of money that he
has to do it i like some of the things
that he's talking about at this stage it
is really all head no beer there's not
much detail on how he'll actually try
and achieve all the things he's saying
but i think authenticating humans is a
great start we know that the bots the
spam the fake accounts are really where
the the cesspit of twitter erupts so i
think that's a wonderful thing the town
square as well i think is a great
concept but he's also got to realize
that town squares even archaically are
regulated so it can't just be an
absolute free-for-all you need you need
rules you need regulations you need free
speech absolutely but he needs to also
remove the
hypocrisy which i think he's doing yeah
and you say obviously donald trump is
banned yet a bloke committing genocide
is uh is still on the platform exactly
that's the hypocrisy which has to be
eliminated and you've done some great
work in going after trolls vicious
trolls and getting them made properly
accountable which is one of the things
elon musk says he'll do but jimmy wells
he said he's going to create a situation
where you've got to be identifiable to
be on the platform and
all of that you though are very
skeptical about musk being an effective
owner of twitter why
yeah i mean i think it's a couple of
things so first of all i mean you know
the the one of the most famous and
incredibly talented twitter trolls in
history takes over twitter what could
possibly go wrong
um but when we look at his his promises
about free speech okay good but it's not
really clear what that means this idea
of identifying everyone on the platform
though that's going to be very very hard
and it does raise a lot of really
complicated questions people are using
twitter
as a support group mechanism they're
talking to people in in lots of ways
that aren't huge and in the public guy
with millions of followers
and i think that's a very difficult
thing to say oh let's not have that
anymore i mean it's very hard isn't it
to regulate any of these things properly
like i mean on your platform for example
wikipedia my eldest son is actually here
tonight to watch the show and he
he waged a several years long battle
with some
somebody out there who kept changing my
wikipedia entry on a tiny point a
factual point to make me the youngest of
four children when i'm the oldest which
meant every profile that ever occurred
about me had me the youngest of four
kids and every time my son edited it
back whoever this was changed it back
again oh dear how do you that's a it's a
little trivial thing doesn't really
matter but all it meant was that when
people looked at wikipedia on my site
they just got a wrong piece of
information every time how and that's
just a small thing on wikipedia how does
elon musk do you think have any kind of
regulatory system which allows free
speech that doesn't allow the kind of
cesspit stuff that we see all day long
so one of the things about wikipedia is
like our job is actually a lot easier we
we don't say we're a wide open free
speech platform we say we're an
encyclopedia you need reliable sources i
imagine in your case if profiles said it
then suddenly there's a bunch of sources
that maybe got it from us and then they
print it and we think of the journalists
or the sources we call it cytogenesis
it's sort of a circular thing that can
happen but in general we don't allow
people to come on and just sort of say
whatever random thing is on their mind
and when you do
then you're really into this area of uh
really complicated questions about
freedom of expression uh you know how do
you determine what's just a snarky
comment versus what's actually abusive
okay there aren't easy answers no it's
none of this is easy i don't think at
all but i do erin i come back to my
initial gut feeling about elon musk is
that i like his basic principle position
that he wants to enrage the far left and
the far right equally because he wants
them all to basically be put back in
their box and allow the vast majority of
people who are reasonably not extreme at
all um to have a proper debate and
conversation again um and not feel that
they're being hindered or censored
absolutely and that's what we've managed
to do here in australia with the new
laws that we have and look the threshold
for what would be considered criminal
threatening harassment is incredibly
high it's akin to that of the criminal
code and and that's what you need in a
space like twitter you want robust
debate you want people to be able to
disagree you want differences of opinion
regardless of what side of politics
you're from regardless of where you're
from in the world but you cannot have a
free-for-all platform where people are
allowed to threaten to rape other
people's children you spoke to sharon
osborne and you look at the damage
that's done so i would like elon musk to
not just look at at advocating for free
speech which i know it's a mountain that
you want to die on and not not want to
but that you would you'd be willing to
it's so important but he needs to
eradicate the crap that has made twitter
just a vile platform by the way
since august last year and happiest i've
been well it's not just twitter though i
mean on instagram you know i've got a
police case going through now with
somebody
somebody made specific death threats to
one of my children uh on on his
instagram page
it was in the in the sort of period of
all that meghan markle thing on the
morning show and that's still going
through the wheels of justice because i
just thought you're not i'm not having
that even someone making everything and
that's why the laws in australia are so
good and they're world first is because
they cover everything it's not about one
platform doing something specifically
these are laws that cover every single
social media platform and it makes the
online world safer and better for
everyone erin gotta leave it there great
to talk to you come back soon please
jimmy thank you so much as well i'm a
huge fan of wikipedia by the way
despite my my fact that i am actually
the oldest actually jimmy could you
change my photo and my wiki feed rating
is low too we'll take a look none of us
could be on tv without wikipedia let's
be honest jimmy thank you uh great to
talk to you both i'm simpson next the
world's most famous transgender woman
former athlete reality tv star and
campaigner caitlyn jenner will be live
and unsensitive after the break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
it's become one of the thorniest debates
in society today should trans women
athletes be allowed to compete in
women's sport well better to talk to
frankly an olympic gold medalist as a
male athlete and i'm gonna be the most
famous trans one in the world now
caitlyn jenner caitlin i'm so happy to
have you on the show thank you very much
well it is my pleasure but first pierce
let's let's clear the air here um
i was asked to do this show like a month
ago
in the last couple of weeks i saw
and i wound up canceling about two weeks
ago why because i saw what she did to
president trump our president who i have
a lot of respect for
um and like he was walking out you
sensationalized the promo to build up
ratings and all this and i i thought to
myself i don't want to be part of that
and so i canceled but since then um and
i stand by what i did but since then
we've had a chance to talk talk to your
producers i feel pretty confident that
you won't do that to me i'm not going to
over socialize this caitlyn at all i'm
delighted to have got you back on the
show and all i would say about the promo
is i know donald trump through celebrity
apprentice which i won and he did those
kind of promos on me every night to get
people watching so all's fair in love in
promo
however however let's turn let's turn to
the main event of this this interview
you you're perfectly qualified caitlyn
to talk about this because i have a
strong view that i support trans rights
to fairness and equality but in issues
like sport and women's sport not to the
point where it starts to degrade the
fairness and equality for women
competitors in in sport for example
you've competed as a man hugely
successfully
and now you've transitioned to be a
woman what is your view about this
well i've been you know first of all
you're right we have to uh we have to do
the best we can here but
um i have said from the beginning and i
stand with it that i don't want
biological boys to compete against women
and girls in sports it's just not fair
now obviously over the last six months
especially uh because of leah thomas um
at the university of pennsylvania
um she had been on the boys team uh just
a few years earlier
um
i do not blame her
she played within the rules
but she dominated
she had gone through male puberty her
lungs are bigger her back's bigger her
hands are bigger she just has a
tremendous advantage in swimming in the
pool against the women and you know and
she proved that
um so i don't have a problem with her i
have a problem with the ncaa
that we have to change the rules
we have to do a better job because the
bottom line is
we have to keep it fair
and i don't want to ruin women's sports
or discourage women from getting into
sports because they think oh my gosh i'm
gonna have to compete against a bunch of
guys i mean i totally agree it's not
fair i totally agree caitlyn but what i
would also say is i don't want to expose
trans people to mockery which is now
going on with this debate because it
looks so ridiculous that you see leah
thomas just dominating women's sport and
i think that trans people who don't want
to be part of any big angry debate about
this want to go about their lives in
peace and quiet and get on with it i
think they're being affected adversely
by this debate and it seems to me
nobody's prepared to put the herd of the
parapet and go look this is clearly
unfair and wrong
here's how we're going to change things
if you were in charge of changing things
to make it fair what is the answer
should trans women athletes for example
compete against men should trans
athletes have their own category now of
competition given there are more and
more trans athletes what's the answer
well here's pierce here's here's the
problem we have here this is a very very
complicated issue just like being trans
is very complicated
um it's very it's there's no right
there's no right answer here pierce um
if you just say
you know no trans athletes um you know
in sports uh well what about female to
male
they're trans that's 49 of the
population 51
are male to female um if we
what happens to the young
uh trans uh
athletes who transitioned some of them
when they're five six seven years old
they take uh hormone uh blockers and
they grow up as little girls their whole
life they have no advantage whatsoever
you know over the other girls
and what do we do there so it almost has
to be treated on an individual basis but
i think the first thing we have to do is
we
we have to make the qualifying for a
trans athlete a little bit more
difficult for them to be able to compete
because i think the number one thing we
have to do is protect women's sports i
mean you've never seen cases
well you never see you you mentioned
there people who transition from female
to male but you never see
any issue there on the sporting side
because they never have an unfair
advantage you know the key point really
about i guess trans women athletes is
they have an unfair natural biological
advantage that's the number of the
problem
if they went through male puberty yeah
you're absolutely right
i went through male puberty okay
i mean i don't even play i mean i play a
lot of golf yeah and at our club i mean
i play with the women a lot by the way
appears the women are a lot more fun to
play with than the men but the
conversation's much better but they
always ask you know say hey we've got a
tournament coming up yeah we've got a
tournament coming up you want to play
with us
and you know when i'm there i say oh
that would be fun but then i never show
up
why because it's just honestly it's i
don't i would never want to take a
trophy away from one of the other i love
the ladies at our club they're wonderful
i wouldn't want to take i can out drive
them by a hundred yards yeah exactly you
know and yeah
yeah and it's just my arms are longer
i'm six one
um what i got left over is more than
what most people ever had
and so i it just wouldn't be fair okay
so uh
i don't play in that i'll be honest with
you leah thomas is
you know honestly leah thomas is one of
the
toughest one of the hardest uh
one of the worst things that happened to
the trans community yeah i agree because
it's such
bad publicity yeah i've met so many
wonderful trans people doing wonderful
things living their life authentically i
hope leah thomas it's over for her now
because she's
out of college and i just hope she has a
wonderful life
being trans is not easy
um and i hope she enjoys the rest of her
life and has a good life you know okay
really i completely what leah did is we
need to look at the rules i agree listen
i completely agree with you i don't want
i want ill will to anyone involved in mr
b i just want fairness and equality i
don't want women's women's rights to be
eroded at the altar of political
correctness and a scaredness to have a
debate caitlyn we've got to leave it
there it's been a brilliant uh interview
thank you come back soon i'd love to
talk to you again i want you the regular
game
pleasure
yeah absolutely yeah i think we'll have
fun it's really good
you got it lovely to talk to you caitlyn
jenner oh that's it from me remember
whatever you're up to this weekend make
it unsensitive
good night
[Music]
i'm tom newton-dunn and this is talk tv
the most memorable moment in my career
without sounding completely conceited it
has to be interviewing president trump
in the open office in the white house
particularly little red button he had on
his desk i have no idea what he did is
he went on one of more moves he's going
to launch a nuclear strike on north
korea or open up a shark pit that i'd
then fall into
turned out he pressed it right at the
end of the interview and he walked a
butler with a tray carrying it dark
it was a diet
[Music]
talk tv news at nine
good evening i'm zora suleiman a british
man who's been killed in ukraine has
been identified as 36 year old scott
sibley it's understood he died fighting
against russian troops as a volunteer in
support of ukraine's military but this
hasn't yet been confirmed by officials
boris johnson says watching porn in the
house of commons is unacceptable it's
after claims this week that a tory mp
was caught watching explicit content on
their phone in the chamber
and talk tv's sharon osbourne is
returning to america to be with her
husband aussie after he tested positive
for covert in an emotional interview for
talk tv the presenter broke down in
tears saying she's very worried about
him and you can hear more from sharon on
the talk up next
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you